[Applaus]
kein thema treibt die politik in
europäischen staaten mehr als migration
es ist mittlerweile sogar zu einem
potentiellen spaltpilz in der eu
geworden doch eine gemeinsame problem
sicht und strategie sind dringend nötig
heute in vechta kompakt migration eine
globale herausforderung
[Musik]
migration ist ein alltägliches phänomen
doch wovon reden wir wir reden von
freiwilliger und erzwungener migration
etwa eine milliarde menschen gelten als
migranten drei viertel davon haben den
wohnsitz innerhalb des landes und ein
viertel außerhalb ihres landes verlegt
die zahl der aus unterschiedlichen
gründen vertriebenen betrug laut uno im
jahr 2017 68 einhalb millionen menschen
der großteil fahren im eigenen land
zuflucht mehr als 25 millionen menschen
flohen ins ausland
etwa drei millionen suchten um asyl an
global gesehen zieht es die meisten
migranten in die usa gefolgt von
deutschland russland und saudi arabien
was veranlasst nun menschen ihren
wohnsitz aufzugeben im zusammenhang mit
wanderbewegungen sind folgende vier
faktoren von besonderer bedeutung
bevölkerungsentwicklung bewaffnete
konflikte das politische system samt
wirtschaft sowie umwelt zur
bevölkerungsentwicklung die
weltbevölkerung liegt aktuell bei knapp
acht milliarden menschen 2050 sollen es
laut un prognosen rund zehn milliarden
seien in den eu staaten leben derzeit
etwas über 500 millionen menschen das
wird sich bis 2050 nicht wesentlich
ändern
man erwartet dass das durchschnittsalter
in der eu im selben zeitraum von circa
42 derzeit auf knapp 47 jahre steigen
wird
dabei schrumpft die bevölkerung im
erwerbsfähigen alter erheblich der
anteil älterer menschen steigt rasant
zur situation in afrika die bevölkerung
wird sich in den nächsten 30 jahren von
aktuell 1 3 milliarden menschen auf um
2,4
milliarden beinahe verdoppeln also
jährlich um 30 bis 40 millionen wachsen
das durchschnittsalter liegt aktuell bei
19 eineinhalb jahren
afrika hat die jüngste bevölkerung der
welt mehr als 220 millionen sind
zwischen 15 und 24
ähnlich die lage im nahen und mittleren
osten statt heute knapp 600 millionen
menschen dann 860 millionen leben werden
in vielen ländern bilden junge menschen
unter 30 sogar die bevölkerungsmehrheit
häufig geht das mit steigender
jugendarbeitslosigkeit mit protesten
politischen unruhen und gewalt einher
das führt zum aspekt bewaffnete
konflikte diese sind eine hauptursache
für knapp 70 millionen binnenvertriebene
und flüchtlinge 2017 zählte man 36
bewaffnete konflikte drei viertel davon
fanden in afrika und im nahen osten
statt dritter aspekt das politische
system und wirtschaft ein wesentlicher
grund für wanderbewegungen ist oft das
politische system so sehen sich viele
menschen wegen korruption verfolgung
feten und misswirtschaft und
perspektivenlosigkeit genötigt
auszuwandern vierter aspekt
umweltveränderungen klima und
umweltbedingte phänomene werden
zukünftig immer häufiger anlass für
wanderbewegungen sei so wurden 2017
deutlich mehr menschen wegen
umweltkatastrophen intern vertrieben als
wegen bewaffneter konflikte ein anderer
punkt aktuell sind 3,6 milliarden
menschen von wasserknappheit betroffen
bis 2050 könnten es über 5 milliarden
sein
dazu kommen die versalzung von
anbauflächen in folge des steigenden
meeresspiegels und die ausbreitung von
wüsten laut uno werden in den nächsten
zehn jahren mehr als 130 millionen
menschen ihr zuhause verlassen müssen
knapp die hälfte davon in afrika südlich
der sahara
was bedeutet das aus europäischer
perspektive
die dargestellten trends sind realitäten
auf die sich einzustellen gilt
vereinfacht kann man sagen die vier
treiber in faktoren erfordern ein bündel
an kurz mittel und langfristigen
maßnahmen die aber gleichzeitig zu
setzen sind
es geht um die steuerung und kontrolle
von migrationsbewegungen richtung europa
um eine selektive gezielte zuwanderung
um integrationsmaßnahmen sowie um die
einhaltung von asyl um menschenrechts
verpflichtungen
das hat nämlich große auswirkungen auf
die eigene glaubwürdigkeit der eu als
wertegemeinschaft
außerdem sind eu-intern nötig ein
abgestimmtes vorgehen in allen bereichen
inklusive zuwanderungsregelungen eine
intensive kooperation mit herkunfts und
transitländern die entwicklung flexibler
schutz und kontrollmechanismen die
förderung von entwicklung samt
bekämpfung der korruption und einsätze
zur eindämmung und beendigung
bewaffneter konflikte sowie zur stärkung
des staatswesens
ein kurzer ausblick wanderbewegungen sie
ein weltweites phänomen
sie werden in den nächsten 30 jahren
zwangsläufig zunehmen
europa wird weiterhin davon betroffen
sind in der eu muss man daher die
herausforderungen annehmen die ja auch
chancen und möglichkeiten bieten
überraschungen wird es zwar immer geben
aber viele entwicklungen sind
vorhersehbar
es geht somit darum sich darauf
einzustellen entsprechende strategien zu
entwickeln und konsequent und
geschlossen zu handeln